a bot ground beef for two euros and
$0.99 chicken breast for 279 and these
salami I got for one euro and 39 cent
how can meet be so cheap well I've
already had a look at intensive
livestock farming and the suffering it
can mean for animals but what about the
people working in the meat industry at
Germany's biggest hog slaughterhouses up
to 30,000 peas as lotted cleaned and
packaged every day workers report
extremely demanding conditions both
physically and mentally it's cold and
there's a lack of natural light the
workers have to be extremely careful so
that they don't cut or stab themselves
metal gloves are supposed to help
prevent that from happening but
accidents occur nonetheless if the
knives become dull you can only work the
meat by using a lot of force and then
the next Pig arrives and you need force
again because it's impossible to work
with those dull knives I buy myself
knives now and again but that's never
enough either
it's outrageous the company doesn't
provide some of the things they should
they make promises but usually
everything is delayed the workers in the
production lane are often not employed
by the slaughterhouse directly many come
from Eastern Europe and work for
subcontractors that's not surprising
after all EU citizens are permitted to
work in any other EU country but the
wages in Western Europe are much higher
than in the East the subcontractors get
a fixed price for slaughtering and
butchering a certain number of Peaks and
report suggests that subcontractors
often end up exploiting workers in order
to turn a profit they try to save where
they can on one of the most costly
factors for meat producers labor we
talked to Michael and read Sookie from
the food industry Association which
represents the German meat industry
German medians tree as very strong
competitors Poland as ill and Asia for
the
poultry industry and Spain and China for
the pig sector in all those countries
labor costs are much lower than in
Germany so the price for labor is very
important German law says all workers
must be paid the minimum wage and what
is that well nine year olds 19 cents per
hour in 2019 and nine-year-olds 35 cents
in 2020 but workers say many
subcontractors don't play by the rules
the worst thing is that you realized
that they keep the money for themselves
instead of paying fair salaries to the
employees I came here to work I don't
care how much I have to work at the
production line as long as I get paid in
the end my effort is worth it if my work
is not valued and paid for then I'll
speak openly to my boss I was told three
times that if I don't like something I
can go he said he would help me write my
resignation
sometimes the payment at the end of the
month is even zero we saw one pay slip
saying the whole salary was withheld due
to unspecified contractual penalties a
recent investigation by germany's most
populous state north rhine-westphalia in
to the meat industry criticized a number
of practices they include unpaid hours
and paid holiday pay shifts exceeding 16
hours a day and lack of safe and
adequate work tools people are under so
much pressure
they are totally unhappy and broken
people all you do is work go home and
sleep and then return to work or you
feel miserable some workers would faint
very often on the production lines
because of exhaustion others would get
injured they would be taken aside and an
ambulance would come to collect them
piatra Mazurek provides counseling to
Eastern European migrant workers most of
his clients work in the meat industry
the working conditions in the meat
industry are one of the most precarious
as long as we have subcontractors in
such a big extent in this branch we will
have the problems
employees and unions criticized the meat
industry's reliance on subcontractors so
why do big companies stick to it the
contract companies has a connections to
the East European labor markets it's
very difficult for German companies to
hire workers directly in their home
countries the European workers they
trust their own companies which hire
them in Dec in the home countries and
then make the contract here there's a
slaughter horses but Trust is lacking
among the workers we talked to both in
their employers but also in the German
labor laws intended to protect workers
professor Stephane Greiner is an expert
on German labor law he says the problem
is not with the laws themselves but that
too few controls are carried out such
subcontractors are more often than not
economically weak companies it's
necessary here to ensure that existing
regulations are observed and implemented
we don't have a problem with the
regulations we have a problem with the
lack of control the number of federal
inspections has actually decreased by
sixty percent between 2009 and 2018 but
when inspections do take place and are
done properly they have uncovered
unscrupulous practices the investigation
in Germany's North rhine-westphalia
examined the working conditions in large
slaughterhouses with thousands of
employees in 26 of the 30 companies
tested there were breaches of labor
regulations in reaction to this
investigation
the state's minister of labor Sayed
foreign contract workers are
particularly affected they already
struggled to make use of their rights
due to language barriers we cannot and
do not want to see how foreign workers
in our country are exploited and how
illegal structures and a mine fair
competition the hash working conditions
contribute to an environment
where many workers don't stay long it's
a system that is in constant demand for
new people and so far there are still
enough people willing to start working
in these jobs even if it means some end
up physically or mentally unable to keep
doing the work but is there a clear path
towards better labor practices
well we visited a slaughterhouse which
claims to do things differently and
indeed instead of giving all the
responsibility to subcontractors they
employ their own workforce that's a
characteristic shared by only two of the
thirty companies that investigators say
can be rated as comparatively good the
thing is well you where you to meet our
value to our employees but if someone
says it's only possible to work with
subcontractors living normally and in
Poland in Romania or in Bulgaria
that's silly it's only much cheaper
however the meat that is produced in
this facility is also more expensive
than the meat coming from the big
slaughterhouses well for consumers it
can be very difficult to find out about
the conditions under which a particular
meat product was produced but one thing
is clear cheap meat is often made
possible by cheap labor and that can be
linked to questionable labor practices
possibly something to keep in mind for
grocery shoppers who are concerned about
how their food is produced
you